en el último vídeo sacamos la función de
masa de probabilidad de la variable x
donde la variable x es el número de
canastas anotadas en seis tiros libres
suponiendo que la probabilidad de anotar
un tiro libre es de 70% y al final del
vídeo te propuse que graficar as estas
probabilidades ahora me puse a pensarlo
y no está de más que yo también lo
gráfico porque al final de cuentas la
gráfica de la función de masa de
probabilidad si te muestra cómo funciona
la variable aleatoria entonces lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es graficar
esta función de masa de probabilidad por
aquí que vamos a poner el eje de las 10
por aquí y aquí vamos a poner las
probabilidades y el eje de las x por acá
y aquí van a estar los posibles valores
de x estas son las probabilidades con
las que x toma distintos valores y la
más alta es 32.4 entonces vamos a poner
por aquí
40 estamos tomando las probabilidades en
porcentaje así es que si por aquí hasta
el 40% de probabilidad más o menos por
aquí está el 20
y por aquí el 10 10 por ciento de
probabilidad y
30% de probabilidad y en el eje de las
equis vamos a poner los valores que
puede tomar x x puede ser igual a 0 o
puede ser igual a 1
a 2
a 3 a 4 a 5 o x puede ser igual a 6
aunque y porque x es la cantidad de
canastas anotadas en seis tiros libres
entonces vamos a graficar estas
probabilidades cuál es la probabilidad
de que x sea igual a cero pues es punto
1 % y eso prácticamente no lo vamos a
ver en la gráfica entonces voy a poner
una rayita por aquí luego queremos ver
cuál es la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 1 ese es uno por ciento y
también va a ser una raya muy pequeña
que estamos menos por aquí
este es el 1% y luego cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 2 pues
esa es 6 por ciento y 6 por ciento está
más o menos por aquí entonces tenemos
por aquí esta probabilidad de que x
sea igual a 2
y la probabilidad de que sea igual a 3
es 18.5 aunque hay eso ya está mejor eso
es más o menos por aquí entonces esta es
la probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3
todo esto de aquí
y la probabilidad de que x sea igual a 4
es 32.4 más o menos por aquí
esta probabilidad de aquí
y ahora la probabilidad de que ello sea
igual a 5 es 30.3 ligeramente más
pequeño que esto
por aquí
y finalmente la probabilidad de que x6
es 11.8 por ciento o sea por aquí
estuve aquí y listo
y tal vez esto parece más como un
ejercicio de cómo hacer un programa pero
sí es útil porque nos ayuda a visualizar
cómo se distribuye la probabilidad a lo
largo de todos los posibles valores de x
aquí podemos ver claramente cómo la
probabilidad está más hacia este lado y
estos valores de aquí son muy
improbables pero bueno otra cosa que
está muy interesante es jugar con los
números jugar con las probabilidades
para ver cómo se va modificando la
función de masa de probabilidad y eso lo
puedes hacer en cualquier hoja de
cálculo